[Musique]
bonjour françois bayrou bonjour nous
allons évoquer en longueur les
propositions vous avez remise hier au
conseil économique social et
environnemental sur la dette vous
proposer de la cantonner et de ne
commencer à rembourser qu'en 2030 vous
allez nous expliquer tout ça mais
d'abord jean castex va s'exprimer ce
soir ça sera à suivre sur france info à
18 heures et hier le ministre de la
santé olivier ferrand s'est rendu à
dunkerque après nice il a annoncé le
confinement pour les deux prochains
week-ends au moins à partir de demain
soir avant éventuellement d'autres
décisions territoriale la situation
épidémique se dégrade dans notre pays
la percée du variant britannique est
telle que le nombre de diagnostics
augmente désormais jour après jour
nous avons effacé en une semaine les
deux semaines de baisse consécutive que
nous avions enregistré jusqu'ici
certains départements restent en dessous
des seuils d'alert plusieurs se situe au
dessus du seuil d alerte est même
nettement au dessus pour ces
départements
je le dis c'est prochains jours seront
cruciaux voire décisif il ya donc une
inquiétude qui est maintenant nationale
françois bayrou qu'est ce que vous
attendez de jean castex le premier
ministre ce soir il me semble que la
ligne du gouvernement est assez clair au
fond on sent bien que le président de la
république a choisi de ne pas re confiné
aussi longtemps que cela sera possible
naturellement les yeux du gouvernement
et des responsables sont fixés sur
l'épidémie sur ce qui se passe sur
l'aggravation parfois petit aggravation
parfois importantes aggravation que l'on
observe dans les départements français
et je crois que le gouvernement est prêt
à prendre des mesures ciblées locales
pour ralentir freiner autant que
possible la propagation d'un département
en france hors département au
département ou métropole ou zones
urbaines c'est à voir
je trouve que la ligne de la souplesse
en face des réalités locales
en face de la réalité de l'épidémie de
la transmission du virus comme elle est
observée est une bonne et juste ligne et
c'est une ligne qui est apparue il ya
seulement quelques jours pourquoi ne pas
l'avoir utilisé plus tôt je crois
qu'elle a été utilisée plus tôt puisque
vous avez observé qu'il y a
ministre de la santé vient de le dire à
l'instant on a connu des semaines de
répit et c'était et c'était bien le cas
moi j'ai trouvé que le choix du
président de la république respectueux
de cette attente que les français ont de
pouvoir tout de même conserver une vie
en commun
on ne peut pas mettre tout un pays sous
cloche à des ternes âme ça n'est plus
possible aujourd'hui les français ne
l'accepterai plus ce serait ce sera
peut-être nécessaire
vous voyez bien que que tout le monde
conserve cette arme s'il le fallait
mais si on peut l'éviter c'est mieux
penser aux enfants et penser aux
étudiants pensez à tous ceux qui ont
besoin d'aller travailler
pour tout cela il faut maintenir cette
possibilité de rencontre qui fait la vie
d'un pays françois bayrou l'argument
contre le traitement à la carte c'était
de rendre au fond le la lutte contre la
crise sanitaire illisible souvenez vous
c'est à dire un mot t oui un côté nom et
c'était compliqué moi je j'ai beaucoup
de compréhension à l'égard de ceux qui
ont la responsabilité entre les mains
parce que personne ne peut dire que
c'est facile et personne ne peut dire
que où que ce soit dans le monde n'a
trouvé la réponse
ça va très vite et où journée ça va très
bien tant le virus mute il ya des
variants comme vous dites qu'ils qui
viennent peu à peu compliqué l'épidémie
vous pensez qu'il faut de la solidarité
je pense au vaccin c'est à dire donner
aux régions les plus touchées les
vaccins disponibles
1 je pense que la seule issue c'est la
vaccination est gelée défendu à votre
micro suffisamment souvent pour ses
lacets la seule issue possible et 2
pour l'instant ce qui freine la
vaccination c'est uniquement la
production de doses de vaccins mais
d'ici quelques semaines ou quelques mois
ce problème va être réglé
on est en train d'installer à pau en
particulier une unité de production de
vaccin qui va produire un million de
doses par semaine et chaque dose ses
vins chaque flacon ses vingt douze de ma
maison
toutes ces doses sont pas forcément
destiné aux français non bien sûr que
non
des doses qui sont mises en commun au
niveau européen en janvier mais c'est
tout à fait normal et légitime on va pas
comment dirais-je d'analyser les vaccins
en pensant que c'est bien qu'on les ait
nous et les autres pas tout ça est une
oeuvre de solidarité à l'intérieur de la
société française et entre les sociétés
européennes et même entre les pays du
monde aux lavandes der leyen l'europe et
l'union très critiqué dans sa gestion
vaccinale sur les stocks sur les les
contrats avec les labos jean français
qui lit je vais vous dire si vous
trouvez dans la situation actuelle des
gens qui ne sont pas critiqués s'est
probablement qu'ils ne font rien jeu où
les gens il sera miens par exemple sont
félicités pour la qualité de leur
campagne ils ont pris des risques
puisque le contrat qu'ils ont passés
avec pfizer ça a été de dire les données
vous sont ouvertes celle des millions
d'israéliens vacciner ce c'est une
c'est là c'est la preuve d'un
gouvernement qui a fait face aux
urgences à l'urgence et c c'est plutôt
un bon modèle j'espère que d'ici
quelques semaines
est ce que vous avez observé combien la
france a rattrapé ce qu'on appelait son
retard en vaccination
on est au même niveau effectivement de
l'allemagne ou l'italie
quasiment eu quelques six semaines mais
le niveau européen dans son ensemble
semble assez faible comparé aux
etats-unis au royaume-uni qu'est sortie
de l'union européenne c'est ça aussi ce
décalage qui est critiquée je participe
pas aux critiques il y aurait trop à
flers travail rouleront à sénéchal
évoqué l instant israël vous êtes
favorable pour nous en france un
passeport vaccinale gelé toujours été
alors je sais pas si c'est le bon terme
je sais pas le toucher je sais le mal
bras une certificat de vaccination
il ya un an des suppléments je pense que
la société française
pensez aux salles de spectacles à la
culture aux universités à tout ce qui
touche à l'école et à la jeunesse
et puis à la possibilité pour les plus
âgés de de ressortir sans crainte
tout cela dépend de la vaccination et je
suis toujours en exemple le fait que en
france même pour aller en guyane qui est
qui et la france on a besoin d'une
vaccination contre la fièvre jaune et si
vous n'avez pas la carte de vaccination
vous entrez pas en guyane et personne ne
s'en plaint et chaque bébé français
reçoit je sais pas combien 10-11
vaccination sont obligatoires voilà onze
vaccination et ça ne choque personne
et c'est comme ça qu'on a fait reculer
des maladies terrifiante comme la
poliomyélite françois bayrou on va
continuer de parler du vaccin qui est en
ce moment d'ailleurs en discussion au
sein de l'union européenne de la réponse
face à cette pandémie et de vos
propositions sur la gestion de la crise
l après crise juste après un coup d'oeil
sur le fil info à 20h40 avec pauline
renoir
obligation de faire un test pcr pour
traverser la frontière entre l'allemagne
et la moselle ça concerne les
déplacements non professionnel et ça
commence ce lundi
dunkerque confiné dès demain soir et
pour les deux prochains week-ends les
hôpitaux sont saturés le taux
d'incidence du virus est deux fois
supérieur à ce qu'il était au printemps
dernier une dizaine de territoires sont
dans le rouge dans le nord dans l'est et
le sud-est il faut s'attendre à ce que
ça se dégrade ailleurs l'analyse de
pascal crêpés sur france info
épidémiologiste à rennes jean castex
donne une conférence de presse ce soir
ça me préoccupe et j'aimerais savoir si
quelqu'un a fauté le président de la
fédération française de rugby banque
était sur le foyer du virus chez les
bleus bernard laporte invité de france
info répond à la demande
d'investigations de la ministre des
sports le 15 doit jouer dimanche face à
l'ecosse un conducteur de rer agressé
hier soir trafic interrompu sur le rer a
entre cergy et le haut et nanterre toute
la journée
un mouvement social sans préavis a été
lancé ce matin le chauffeur aurait
demandé à un voyageur de porter le
masque france info
8 30 france info laurent sénéchal
jean-françois qui vive françois bayrou
vous avez fait vous êtes haut
commissaire au plan et vous avez fait
hier devant le conseil économique social
et environnemental des propositions sur
la dette la gestion de cette dette qui
est générée en ce moment par la réponse
apportée à la crise vous dites il faut
ne commencer à rembourser cette dette
générée par le quoi qu'il en coûte en
quelque sorte qu'à partir de 2030
c'est possible ça il ya une très grande
inquiétude des français sur la dette
inquiétude parce que incompréhension au
fond les français disent et à moi en
particulier en raison des combats que
j'ai menés sur ce sujet 10 mais vous
nous avez expliqué pendant des années
qu'on n'avait pas d'argent
et puis tout d'un coup là vous en
trouvez comme vous en avez trouvé il ya
12 ans sur une autre crise financière et
je pense très important que on essaie de
fixer avec les français c'est la
proposition que je fais une méthode pour
prendre en charge cette dette là qu'est
ce que c'est cette dette
premièrement c'est la réponse d'urgence
jeudi une réponse de guerre qu'il
fallait apporter parce que nous étions
devant une menace de vie ou enfin de
mort c'était une question du cas c'était
une question de vie ou de mort pour la
société française
c'est comme dans une guerre quand il ya
une guerre bah vous faites pas des
comptes vous achetez tout le matériel
qu'il faut toutes les armes qu'il faut
vous équiper les forces armées pour
repousser l'envahisseur et sauver le
pays c'est ce qu'on a fait on a dépensé
quelque chose comme 90 milliards dix les
chiffres officiels
86 je crois exactement en 2020 pour
faire face pour aider les commerçants à
traverser cette crise les industriels à
traverser cette crise prendre en charge
des salaires des charges sociales
proposer des emprunts c'est
l'enveloppent et scénographie
aujourd'hui deux mois après on a sans
doute dépensé encore une vingtaine de
milliards quelque chose comme ça on est
donc au dessus des 100 110 milliards et
on va dépenser encore au moins autant
jusqu'à la sortie de l'église en amont
appréciation 200 un peu plus de 200
milliards c'est naturellement une
estimation mais sont des chiffres
vertigineux
oui ce sont des chiffres vertigineux
parce que la situation est vertigineux
vous dites il faudra les rembourser
alors ça c'est la première chose la
guerre qu'il a fallu faire dans cette
situation notre vie était menacée
deuxième obligation que je propose de
mettre au même niveau sur l'agenda c'est
que on a découvert pendant cette crise
à quel point la france n avait qu ils
disaient depuis longtemps à quel point
la france était désarmé dans un certain
nombre de secteurs
on a failli manquer de prix de produits
pharmaceutiques on voit aujourd'hui les
difficultés avec le vaccin
il ya des branches entières de
l'industrie qui sont atteintes et ya
surtout en france une absence sur des
marchés essentiels de notre de notre vie
nationale de tous les jours qui fait que
par exemple nous avons un déficit du
commerce extérieur qui fait peur 70 75
milliards de déficit du commerce
extérieur alors que les allemands ont un
excédent de 200 milliards et que
d'autres pays sont au moins à
l'équilibré et celle va falloir les ça
il n'est pas possible pour moi
d'accepter cette situation la paix la
reconquête de l'appareil productif c'est
exactement ça et donc nous devons nous
fixer comme impératif ne dit pas
seulement comme objectif comme impératif
de reconquérir la capacité de l'appareil
productif ses plans marshall françois
bayrou pour moi c'est un plan marshall
c'est l'équivalent on a eu une guerre il
faut assumer la charge de cette guerre
contre le virus et on a aujourd'hui
besoin d'un plan marshall pour
reconstruire et jeudi il faut dix ans
pourquoi parce qu'il ya une chose qu'il
faut ne pas perdre de vue avoir à
l'esprit tous les jours c'est que nous
avons en france
contrat social le plus généreux de tous
les pays du monde
au moins aussi généreux qu'aucun des
pays du monde
et quand on a le contrat social le plus
généreux alors il faut avoir l'appareil
productif pour soutenir ce contrat
social contrat social il est payé par
les impôts et des dons et des
cotisations sociales renoncer s'il n'y a
pas d'activité on est mort mais comment
va le financer ce plan marshall et bien
je précisément nous pouvons emprunter
parce qu'aujourd'hui l'emprunt dans dans
des pays comme le nôtre ça grâce à la
banque centrale européenne est à 0%
il n'ya pas de génération qui avons-nous
et eu cette chance incroyable de pouvoir
se reconstruire en empruntant à 0% à
condition que l'emprunt soit pour
l'investissement
il ya quelque chose de 2 dans lequel on
s'est laissé entraîner qui est une
espèce de deux de chute de l'esprit de
responsabilité qu'on a vécu pendant des
décennies en france
l'emprunt c'est justifié quand il faut
investir préparer l'avenir préparer
notre économie préparer nos équipements
mais l'emprunt ce n'est pas justifiée
quand on veut faire payer à l'emprunt
nos dépenses courantes
alors françois bayrou l'argent on va
dire pas gratuit mais à taux zéro est ce
que ça va durer 1 et imaginons ce serait
dramatique
d'autres épidémies ou nuque du mois
cette épidémie qui rebondir pendant des
années et ce qui tient votre plan
marshall lancé ce scénario là de toute
façon vous qui posez la question essayé
de me proposer une autre réponse que
celle que je fais c'est vous quelle
heure dans un verre mais ça n'est pas si
on veut centre plan audacieux ça n'est
pas p vous piéger
oui il faut des plans audacieux parce
que nous ne pouvons pas laisser la
france dans la situation où elle est
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui que je dis ça
vous fout le vous le savez bien j'ai
fait une campagne présidentielle entière
sur le thème du produire en france
le
et on n'a rien fait on a laissé peu à
peu partir les productions or on est
aujourd'hui à un moment absolument clé
parce que les modes de production sont
en train de changer partout dont le nom
mais de quoi dans le plan marshall
françois bayrou je m'en allais je mets
la reconquête de tous les secteurs ou
des secteurs dans lesquels nous sommes
absents par négligence si j'ose d
exemple clair l'inde le exemple à terre
je vais jouer vous mangez j'en donne 2 à
grands traits un pays qui sait produire
des satellites des fusées des avions des
sous marins nucléaires
une construction bréval de haut niveau
une maîtrise de tout ce qui est
numérique des dates à des algorithmes de
la robotique ce pays là il a tout ce
qu'il faut au sommet de la pyramide de
la production et il n'a pas ce qu'il
faut en bas si vous savez produire des
fusées dédain normalement vous devrez
savoir produire c'est pas moi des
appareils électroménagers long des
appareils ménagers ne plus importer du
de chine
en tout cas avoir des accords qui nous
permettent d'imaginer d'implanter sur
notre sol des unités de production avec
le problème c'est le coût du travail
ouvrier du sort et elle non c'est ce
qu'on dit depuis des décennies il se
trouve qu'aujourd'hui le coût du travail
est en train de décroître dans le dans
l'euphorie de la production des projets
pourquoi parce que vous avez de la
robotique les robots travaillent 24
heures sur 24 et il travaille avec une
précision absolue
et quand
deuxième exemple je vais prendre un
exemple très très simple et très bête
nous sommes un des premiers producteurs
au monde en europe de pommes de terre
mais nous vendons les pommes de terre à
l'étranger et nous rachetons les pommes
de terre sous forme de chips et de
flocons de purée et nous sommes
déficitaires gravement par centaines de
millions d'euros sur le secteur des
pommes de terre transforme et ça fait un
peu économies de pays en voie de
développement
on vient vous prendre les matières
premières donc faire les chiffres à la
maison envoie des produits et pour
quelles raisons jacques tueur et c'est
comme ça troisième exemple ce sera le
moins cher tout simplement non pas du
tout pas du tout le le nos amis belges
eux voisin jeu j'ai des enfants belges
donc je peux pas je peux pas dire le
contraire ce sont des amis mais ils
n'ont pas de meilleur moyen de
production que nous simplement avec le
temps nous avons laisser s'en aller
un très grand nombre de productions
dernier point le bois nous avons la
deuxième forêt en europe
eh bien nous importons tous les produits
tous les meubles tout le bois façonnés
de l'étranger nous vendons parfois du
braille qui nous revient sous forme de
pop et bien l'idée que tout le pays
gouvernement états et entreprises
grandes entreprises et moyennes
entreprises se dotent d'un pacte qui
nous permettra d'être offensif en face
d'une situation inacceptable
cela est rendu possible parce qu'on peut
aujourd'hui le financer grâce à ce que
la banque centrale européenne nous
permet en emprunts à 0% françois bayrou
vous nous direz dans un instant si vous
avez présenté ce plan chef de l'état
parce que c'est ça qui est important
aussi et surtout ce qu'il en pense juste
après un coup d'oeil sur le fil info à
20h50 avec pauline renoir
les vaccins arrivent dans les cabinets
de médecins la campagne démarre
aujourd'hui chez les généralistes qu'ils
sont trente mille à s'être inscrits pour
recevoir des doses pour leurs patients
priorité aux 50 64 ans qui présentent
des comorbidités le vaccin astrazeneca
en france et bientôt aux états unis
celui de johnson & johnson un vaccin
unidose et qu'ils se gardent au frigo
les autorités américaines confirment son
efficacité contre le virus et ces
variants elles doivent se prononcer sur
sa mise sur le marché aim une dizaine de
départements surveillé de près par le
gouvernement dans le nord l'est et le
sud est
le taux d'incidence grammes jusqu'à 900
cas pour 100000 habitants selon les
zones
on a tout fait pour ne pas en arriver là
mais je comprends la mesure le
témoignage du maire de dunkerque sur
france info à la veille du premier week
end de confiner à partir de lundi et
puis à partir de lundi il faudra
présenter un test négatif pour entrer en
moselle depuis l'allemagne décision du
gouvernement 7 concerne les déplacements
non professionnels
trois cents policiers en renfort à
marseille le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin se rend dans les
quartiers nord aujourd'hui il sera
également question des trafics de
stupéfiants
franceinfo le 8 30 france info laurent
sénéchal jean-françois qui lisent le
haut commissaire au plan
françois bayrou vient de présenter sur
france info son projet pour la gestion
de la dette de l'après crise ce plan
marshall que vous appelez de vos voeux
est ce que emmanuel macron est d'accord
avec vous est ce qu'il à votre blanc
sans alors je ne m'exprime jamais au nom
du président de la république et je ne
rapporte jamais les conversations que je
peux avoir avec du mail
je lui ai évidemment présenté le plan
depuis déjà plusieurs semaines avant de
le rendre public s'est intéressé
maintenant que c'est bon parce que je
pense qu'il est intéressé est ce qu il
signe aussi pour votre proposition de la
proportionnelle aux législatives
ben là l'année prochaine le vous voyez
bien que le président de la république
fait en sorte qu' une réflexion sur ce
sujet et il a bien raison
ça c'est du langage diplomatique cela
non non non c'est du langage absolument
factuel direct et factuel comme j'aime
pourquoi à mon avis on devrait être
désespéré de voir le décrochage entre
les pouvoirs le le sommet de la pyramide
ou ceux qui se croient au sommet de la
pyramide les institutions le parlement
le gouvernement le décrochage entre eux
ce sommet là et là la base des citoyens
du pays qui ne s'y reconnaissent pas qui
ne participe plus aux élections qui se
détournent de tout ça et on devrait être
obsédé par le fait d'en chercher les
causes qu'elle est la cause des
variations en 2017
quelle est la cause première la cause
première ce qui se sentent pas
représentés
il y a des dizaines de millions de
français qui ont des opinions politiques
on peut être en désaccord assez
fortement avec ses opinions ils ont des
opinions politiques et ils n'ont pas de
représentation dans les institutions et
donc santé à veut dire une crise
démocratique assuré est garanti mais la
production position que je fais elle est
toute simple
les français sont égaux devant la
représentation et ils seront tous
représentés au parlement
qu'ils soient des partis majoritaires ou
des partis minoritaires sentait lui et
rennes à l'assemblée ça ne vous fait pas
peur contrairement à une partie devrait
y avoir des élus d'extrême droite ou
d'extrême gauche ou ou écologistes
nombreuses ou du centre il ne peut y
avoir c est lui que s'il ya des
électeurs est ce qu'on représente c'est
pas les partis c'est les électeurs c'est
ce qui en conscience parfois
douloureusement chez eux disent mais
voilà moi je voudrais que ça change
or aujourd'hui on ne représente que les
majorités je suis pas je suis en
confrontation avec marine le pen depuis
longtemps elle a été au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle elle a fait
35% des voix elle est revenue avec un
pour cent des sièges à l'assemblée
nationale vous trouvez que c'est normal
font savoir au barça mais ça n'est pas
qu'elles les premiers signataires de de
la lettre que j'ai proposé que nous en
voyons tous au chef de l'état ses les
écologistes pourquoi ben c'est un
courant qui n'a pas la représentation à
la hauteur à la hauteur de ce qu'il est
vous proposez là fortement aujourd'hui
une proposition de loi déposée par par
votre groupe modem emmanuel macron vous
le sentez candidats pour 2022 est ce que
ça veut dire que il peut valider ce que
ce projet là françois gally vous lui
poserez la question accord mais moi je
sais avec certitude que en 2022
ça doit être une nouvelle étape qui
s'ouvre est pas la poursuite sans rien
changer de l'étape précédente
mais c'est ms du joli l'abri comme
citoyen et je suis sûr que le président
de la république investi des
responsabilités qui sont les siennes et
avec une conscience aiguë de tout ça
vous rappeliez jean françois achilli qu
en effet c'était le thème déjà de 5,2
2017 et c'est la raison pour laquelle
moi je prends les engagements qui ont
été les siens au sérieux et je suis
certain que c'est le moyen de faire
changer les choses
par exemple le rapport entre le
vernement et le et le parlement vous
avez vu que des responsables y compris l
air ont signé cette proposition
je pense à gérard longuet par exemple en
disant c'est le seul moyen de changer
les rapports entre ceux qui gouvernent
et ceux qui représentent les français en
tous les cas ce combat proportionnelle à
celle vaut depuis longtemps c'était
celui aussi de marielle de sarnez
oui c'est celui de notre famille
politique elle était un visage et un
pilier infiniment précieux de cette
famille politique
merci à vous en garde en tête cet
hommage celle qui était votre bras droit
au sein du modem est également dans
votre parcours politique
merci à vous qui nous a quittés